now thousands of civil servants are
walking out today which of course
coincides with budget J I'm joined Now
by Mark sawatka the General Secretary of
the public and Commercial Services Union
which represents civil servants uh mark
thank you for coming in
um why today why is tricon budget day
well good morning well we've been
stroking now since December because the
government's own Workforce has been
given the lowest payoff for anywhere in
the economy two percent
even though 40 000 of them use food
banks 45 000 government workers claim
benefits because they are so poorly paid
and astonishingly today the tax
department hmrc that's on strike for the
first time a third of the entire
department is now on the national
minimum wage 10 pound 42 an hour for
collecting tax overseeing the minimum
wage and enforcing tax regulation so
we're on strike today to draw attention
to the fact that the government's
treating its own employees worse than
anyone else and of course we're joining
seven of the unions on strike today
meaning there's actually 600 000 public
sector workers taking industrial action
your pay demands of around 10 the
government says it's just unaffordable
it's not a starting point for
negotiations
well there are no negotiations
um I've met the minister twice I've met
cabinet officials numerous times they
tell us they're listening the minister
actually told me he was moved by the
testimonies of his own staff that we
gave him that said they were skipping
meals that people are living in poverty
but two percent is what they've given no
food inflation last week was 16 not the
luxuries not caviar these are bread eggs
milk Staples 16 yep when you're on the
minimum wage and you're getting a two
percent pay raise industrial action is
the last resort we've asked for 10
because that's what inflation was but
what we've really said to the government
is put money on the table now and we
will meet you but they're refusing to do
that
there is a word that potentially in the
government we may see the announcement
of a 5.5 public sector pay rise would
that be a sensible starting point that
you could at least get around the table
and start talking or if the government
came and said we want to start talking
about 5.5 percent and they agreed that
that was going to be backdated because
this pay raise we had of two percent
came in March last year then of course
we would make them to talk about it we
would say that 5.5 isn't enough we
certainly start talking around it our
key demands are for the lowest paid and
if I was to tell you that we've just
done a deal with an employer in Scotland
for some of our public sector members
that's delivered a 15 pound an hour
minimum wage and has got pay raises
between 10 and 29 over two years 29 for
the lowest paid it tells you that if in
Scotland you can make progress if in
Wales you can make progress if our
firefighters can make progress with
local authorities why is it only where
it's the conservative government at
Westminster who makes the decisions is
no progress being made anywhere so just
to be clear you are saying that a 5.5
rise would mean that that you would get
around the table but only if it's
backdated because my understanding is
the government saying it won't back date
anything so we must have a backdated pay
award because at the moment people have
had two percent for the last year that's
unacceptable when inflation peaked at 13
due in that period and we wouldn't
settle for 5.5 percent but at least if
the government said we're starting there
with that money on the table we of
course we're getting to talks
unfortunately at the moment they've said
two percent is all you're getting we
will not talk to you so now we're seeing
135 000 civil servants on strike today
but I can tell you that if after today
the government still won't talk later
this week we will be announcing a
significant escalation of that
industrial action which will really see
I think disruption increase because
frankly not getting any pay raises is
not an option for the people we
represent but if the government do say
look you know you want 10 we'll start
talking at 5.5 but forget backdated
isn't now the time to just say right
let's just focus on the future and let's
get get sit down and try and work
something out
well we've made it clear that we will
turn up and meet them anytime
but what we're trying to be realistic
and say is we cannot walk away from
those talks with people having had a two
percent pay raise when they're using
food banks when they're claiming
benefits I mean I'm sure your listeners
would be staggered to know if they go
into a job center if they're getting a
pension or a disability payment or
Universal Credit the people dealing with
them are on the national minimum wage
people making decisions on Asylum
Seekers people who are collecting tax 30
percent of an entire government
department is on the national minimum
wage I think most people would find that
a scandal and would understand there for
why two percent or even five percent
when you pay is that low does not help
you in a cost of living crisis of course
historically the Civil Service hasn't
been amongst the best paid in society
but a lot of people would argue that the
payoff is other benefits very very
comprehensive pensions when they retire
and it's something that they would say
well people know that when they go into
the Civil Service well that's a fair
point because I started in a civil
service 40 years ago in the southwest
valleys in a social Security office and
that was always the argument but 40
years on all of those extra things have
been eroded so now for example our
pensions are far from gold plated in
fact the government had an independent
valuation that told them people were
paying two percent too much for their
pension but they refused to cut the
pension contributions so our pensions
have been eroded terms and conditions
have been eroded and the real proof of
this point is over the last 10 years
because pays gone down in real terms
every single year it's why now a third
of the entire hmrc and the DWP
departments that's 47 000 staff are on
their minimum wage they were not on the
minimum wage five years ago it's because
their pay's gone down everything else
has gone up and if people think that the
government's own employees are now
essentially getting the minimum wage for
administering Frontline services
I think most people would find that
shocking and could see why we're taking
industrial action of course you know
they are alongside lots of other people
who have also seen their pays fall in
real terms it's not something that's
just specific to the Civil Service is it
it's not which is why so many unions are
on strike what I think is specific is we
have the lowest offer the lowest rates
of pay are the parts of the economy are
not having so many minimum wage
employees and I repeat the point that
when the government makes all these
announcements in the budget today
there'll be civil servants who deliver
it we'll collect the tax we will have to
implement the new laws we deliver the
Universal Credit we keep the transport
system running we check the passports at
the borders we have people in prisons
for 10 pound 42 an hour when forty
thousand are using food banks and
skipping meals it's a real Scandal and
the government know this is the case
which is why if you think everyone else
is going on strike when they've been
offered five or six percent I think most
people could understand why with a two
percent offer on those low rates of pay
this is really the last resort and there
will be a lot more of it unless the
government recognize it's a shame on
them that they are having such a level
of inward poverty in the civil service
if they're turning a Blind Eye I'd say
how passionately
this affects you it's really emotional
isn't it it's tragic because I see these
men and women who've dedicated their
life to Public Service who always go the
extra mile they were clapped in the
pandemic they went into work there were
people dying from covid because they
were in work delivering Frontline
Services yet now they're claiming the
benefits that they administer they're
going to the food banks with people in
the communities that they live but
they're delivering government services
they are government employees it's a
national scandal in my view and the
chancellor if you had anything about him
today would recognize it and give the
money that's needed which is not much to
give people a pay rise that means they
can spend money in their local
communities and that they're not living
in poverty Marx Walker thank you very
much